Alright, there you, friend.
That's an ounce of weed and
thanks for supporting small
business. Next!
Hey, could you sell me more than
an ounce?
Sorry, friend, that's the law.
Us simple farming fold respect
the law and eachother.
Oh, it's fine. I'll just go over
the Anderson Weed Farm
and by more there.
Well don't buy weed from
them. Their weed sucks.
It's a long way to drive out
here. I need to make it
worth my while.
Shit! This whol Amazon strike
has more people smoking weed
thank ever.
We have to make sure Tergrity
Weed
stays ahead of the
competition
We need to find a way to get the
weed to the people.
Yea, like a- like a delivery
service.
Some way so people don't have to
drive out here
and even see the other weed
farms.
You know what they got? They got
these e-scooters nowadays.
You mean the things that almost
killed us all on Halloween?
Yea, I 'member.
What if we use e-scooters to get
the weed
directly to the
costumers?
Holy shit, we could have Tegrity
all over town.